させさせてもどうせあのたられば男であろうが出家してやろうと
みんなに勉強はさせますけど
だから無駄にはなりませんね
ものすごく厳密に勉強はさせますけど
弟子にするという話はない
それである日 この我々はこのガンの代わりに遊びで噛む
ある木の実があります
それはもう皮がついていて
刃物でちゃんと皮を抜いて綺麗にして
切って割って かなり硬いんですけどね
皮を殴っちゃいけないんですね
そこでこの子はそれを噛みたくて
この先生のところにそれは木の実があって
それで一つ取って 刃物でそれ切って
丁寧に半分と ごく真剣
真面目に半分切りにしたんです
半分切り分けて 半分チョキンとこの刃物で切って
それを食べて あれは残り半分そのまま置いて帰った
置いて仕事に行ったんですね
で 遠くからこの長老はその子供がやってることを見たんですね
そこで次の日は親呼んだんです
寺に親呼んで あなたの息子をね
連れて帰ってくださいと
それでよ だから何が悪いことしたんですか？何もやってないんです
ただあれで決めたんです
出家にはふさわしくない
何年も寺にいたんだけど
だからここでまあ この私は見たこと
私に私は勉強した時の先生がいたんだから
その先生も結構年でしたし
この先生の先生の話ですとか
もう 100年前の話でしょうと思いますけど
で まあまあわかりませんだけどね
何考えていたかと 一応まあ我々は同じ仏教の環境だから気持ちはわかるんですね
あの長老の あの子供に対してはこの我が子のように愛情は生まれてこない
気持ちはね 全く他人の子供だから
この弟子入りするってことは
この全く他人の子が私の子だよとね
思う気持ちが生まれてこなくて
心配する気持ちね 生まれてこなきゃね
師弟関係は成り立たないんですね
だから この弟子のこと心配で心配でという気持ちが生まれてこない
やはりその子 この子にとしては
そういう気持ちはこれからが生まれないだろうということでしょ
ということは その人は自分のことしか考えない
だから 在家では成功しますけど
出家では成功しませんね
在家では自己中心的で
もう弱肉強食で 誰でも倒して倒して倒して自分だけ偉くなればいいんだけどね
出家では成功する人っていうのは
調和で調和で調和で調和で
みんなに意見を聞いて
みんなの賛成の中で生きていなくちゃいけない
そこで成功するっていうことは大変な仕事
人を倒して私は偉いぞというのは簡単ですけどね
ですから あの出来事で
あの長老はそこまで決めてしまったんですね
だからそれはもう決まり
最終的な判こすための決まりだけでしたけど
ずっと見ていたんだからね
ずっと見ていたんだから
性格は あれを見たら あ
これで決まりと そうやってこの性格を理解して
このきめ細かい人間の行動の中で
この無意識 無意識的に我々の性格は我々を表しているんです
だから本人が知らないだけで
これまるっきりバレてるんですよ
だから恥ずかしいことそういうことなんです
だから本人がすごい頭いいような格好つけてるんだけど
頭は悪いと明確にバレてるんです
だから私は全然怒りませんよと
いつでもニコニコと一生懸命頑張ってるよという
あの 何て言いますか これ表現しようとするんだけど
もう根元はどういう性格というのはすっごくもう外へ明確にバレてるんですね
だから人は無知型ということは
その一つの方法はこれわかりやすいとこなんです
もし人が あの いわゆる計算できないんだと
怒ってるか笑っているか
親切か あるいは厳しいかと
そこはある程度で覚醒だと
そこで組み合わせによってまたね
出てきますから とにかくまあ性格分析っていうのは
アビダンマは七つのテキストでできてまして
一冊はそれですからね
かなりの量なんです こちらでは二
三行で終わってますけど
このテキストでは二行
まあ一応その性格もそう理解してほしいし
これからまあ他人の性格をね
よく分析してあげて ひどい目に遭ってください
[笑い]私はあなたの性格知ってるぞと
で 人はとにかく判断区別しない方が一番いいんです
では まあ私のやり方も一応言いますけど
私は人の性格の判断するためには
まずやり方っていうのは
まず人に顔を見て点満点あげるんです
この人は満点の人間だと
それで自分から満点もらうためにふさわしいかないかと調べるんです
調べるということではなくて
まあ満点でそのようにもう喋ったり話したりすると
あれ これはちょっとちょいとこれはまあ一点マイナスと
あ ちょっと待って この場合は三点マイナスと
そうやって全部点数を減らして減らしていくんです
そこでどこかで止まるところで
その人の本当の実力 能力
性格のところですね そこでこのレベルでまあコミュニケーション取りましょうということになります
で 他の世の中でやることっていうのは
初めから否定する 例えば日本の場合はね
もうお寺 初めからもう出ていけと思って否定して
それで向こう側が必死になって頑張ると
まあまあまあいいんじゃないかと
そうやってすごく何て言いますか
やっと認めるという方法はありますけどね
いわゆる初めからもうあんたダメやと零点だと
そこでまあ点ぐらいあげましょうとか
じゃあまあもう点入れましょうと
それでやっと合格点になったら
まあ合格点だから じゃあいいんじゃないかというふうに認める方法もあります
それは私の性格としては
それはちょっとできないんです
それは初めもうあなた点ですよと言ったら
本人は本当にそうなっちゃうんです
だからそれはかわいそうでしょうし
[笑い]ですからこの
点あげる場合は 本当は私はこういう点出そうと言ったられば
その人を恵まれてる可能性もありますけど
なぜならばわざと点あげたんだから
これからあなたを育てますという責任感がある場合は点あげるんです
だから育てるんだからもう点あげるしか方法ないんです
あんただと じゃあ育ててあげますと言って
1点ずつ 1点ずつもうプラスできるように
もういろいろ工夫してあげると
だから一発で点もらっても面白いというわけでもないんで
それはもうこちらは責任はないんです
まあ堂々とやりましょうと
あんた点満点だと そこで点数減らして自分にふさわしい点数になるという点数の入れ方があります
それはいらない 一応伝統的にはこの 6つに分けて性格分析します
ああ 困ったもんだ そこで瞑想は種類あります
また種類と言えますかね
で あの瞑想っていうのは
このサマタディパッサナーがあって
修行の方法ですね 修行は 3つもあります
そういう言葉も覚えておきましょう
パリカンマ ウパチャーラ
アッパナーという修行のやり方 3つあります
アッパナー これすごい分かりやすい
例えばヴィパッサナー瞑想
シッタクーダーサティったらヴィパッサナーのパリステージですね
パリカンマステージ ウパチャーラステージ
アッパナーステージという段階かな
だからどんな瞑想にしたっても
パリカンマステージがあって
ウパチャーラステージがあって
アッパナーステージがあるんです
それは仏教の瞑想だけじゃなくて
人類の瞑想には全部この 3つのステージがあるんです
で パリカンマっていうのは
この 準備みたいな意味なんですが
いわゆるこの必要な訓練準備するステージ
どんな仕事をしたって
何にしたっても 最初からやらなくちゃいけない
やっておかなくてはならない
いろんなことがあるんですね
準備段階 準備段階とトライアル段階でもあります
では 瞑想の場合は瞑想をやったことはない
それでちゃんと教えてもらって
じゃあじゃあ始めてみますと言って始めて
ずっと頑張っている その頑張っている段階はパリカンマステージなんですね
それはこの音楽とか舞台とかね
そういう例えでわかりやすいと思いますね
例えばあの 何か音楽 なんとか公演やりたいとかね
何か舞台で何か演劇を演奏したいとか
何かある場合はパリカンマステージっていうのは台本があって
ストーリーがあって そういうことはまた音楽だったらいろいろ音楽曲があって
いろんな準備しなくちゃいけないんですね
それでドラマだったらいろいろいろいろ
これもう毎日毎日練習
練習 練習 それで一部一部やってみて
やってみて じゃあもう一回これやりましょうと
じゃああれはダメで じゃあこういう風に
ああ これでいいですよと
ああだこうだとか かなり苦労して
何ヶ月か 時々何年間も
これでパリカルマステージでやってるんです
例えば曲ができても やってる途中でここら辺はもうちょっと変えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
またメロディ変えてみたりとかね
こちらはドよりはミで終わった方がいいんじゃないかとか
あーだこうだとか いろいろ
それからやっぱりこの音は消してましょうとか
いろんなことでやってやってやって長い
ものすごい時間 長いパリカルマステージは
それでウパチャラステージに来るんですね
ウパチャラステージってのはもうそろそろほとんど準備完璧
完成 じゃあそろそろリハーサルやってみようと
リハーサルステージなんですね
リハーサルステージっていうのはほとんど本物と同じレベルでやるんです
もう編集なし そちらはそうじゃなくて
こうやってください リハーサルの場合は言わない
リハーサルだから ちゃんと順番通りに
もう今まで習った習った決まり
やーだこと全部ひとまとめにて
失敗なしにリハーサル全部やる
ですから リハーサルっていうのはほとんど本番と 100%同じなんですね
ウパチャラっていうのはリハーサルステージなんです
で リハーサルも OK 無事終わったら
じゃあ本番だ で リハーサルの場合はリハーサル
ほんのちょっと失敗したらもう一回もできますね
本番は一回だけです 本番では失敗ダメですね
例えばリハーサルやりましたとすると
失敗しました そこでまた指導を受けて
どういうところで何が間違ったかと言うでしょ
じゃあもう一回リハーサルしましょうと言うでしょう
その場合は前のリハーサルというのはウパチャラなんです
リハーサルにならなかったということなんです
リハーサルになったということは
一つも間違いなく OK
二重丸で舞台が終わったならばリハーサルなんです
じゃあ本番に行きましょうということになっちゃいます
そこでリハーサルでちょっと失敗して
それで注意してもらってね
今度は間違うなよと そこのところは
じゃあ本番だよとはいかないんです
やっぱり完全に全部間違わないでリハーサルしたところで本番になっちゃう
そういうこの舞台の世界であるような三段階みたいなもので
瞑想の世界で長い年月かけてパリカルマ
それで瞑想のリハーサルみたいな状態があって
すぐ次に瞑想の本番という禅定ですね
禅定状態が生まれてくる
そういうことで 瞑想も普通の勉強も全部この一応段階に分けた方がいいんですね
だから瞑想の世界では
あの修行することやら
まあ森の中の出家生活やら
毎朝毎晩瞑想することやら
全部パリカルマ瞑想ですね
準備瞑想 そこで一年 二年
三年 四年 五年 六年 七年と決まってない
とにかく瞑想すると そこで間違ったら直してもらう
間違ったら直してもらう
そこで直すところは何もなく瞑想できたっていうことは
ウパチャーラ状態で そこ終わって次の瞬間でアップナー瞑想になります
ということは禅定を作る
統一状態作る 瞑想の結果を出す
だから瞑想 瞑想の結果出す前に結果のようなリハーサル
リハーサルはあります
なんでそういうふうに三つに分けてます？例えば禅定に入る前に禅定のような経験が生まれるんです
そこで止まっちゃったら禅定はしたことはないんですから
かわいそうですね リハーサルだけで終わってもお金入らないでしょ
例えば三年間いろいろそういう稽古をして
してして やっと一つできたと
リハーサルやってみましょうと
すっごい盛大なリハーサルやった
OK やと 本番の日は現れなかったとなるとお金もらわないでしょ
本人から すごい損だけなんですね
だからこの仏教の世界では
瞑想はリハーサルで終わらないように気をつけて三つに分けてます
普通の世界では ほとんどの場合は
この瞑想はリハーサルで終わってる時も見られるし
リハーサルのところかパリカルマのところでできたと誤解するんだからね
あ これぐらいだったらできますよと
ということで終わったりもします
ほとんどの瞑想っていうのはパリカルマのレベルでみんな終わっちゃいますけど
たまに稀な人々はね リハーサルレベルまで持っていって
こういう経験があったんだから
これは悟りだと まさに悟りだと
唯一の解脱者だとそこで決めて
まあ大損するんです ですから
瞑想の場合もそうやって三つの段階あるっていうことは覚えておきましょう
で そのもう一つ言葉 このパリカルマ瞑想の対象はパリカルマニミッタと言うんです
瞑想すると何かニミッタがなければできません
何か瞑想する対象がないと
で ウペチャーラ瞑想の場合はウペチャーラニミッタと言うんです
で 目的対象は違うんですね
そこでアッパナレベルではアッパナニミッタと呼ぶんです
そこら辺理解しないとかなり問題起こるんです
例えばこのパリカルマ準備中の瞑想の場合は
まあ膨らみとか縮みとか
もうお腹の動きとか 鼻の先の空気の流れとかね
いろんなもうクンダリニーのあーだこうだとかね
いろいろなことを妄想したり
模索したり 考えたりやってる
瞑想はもうパリカルマニミッタのレベルなんですね
そこでこのウペチャーラっていうのはリハーサルのレベルだから
この本物本番と同じですから
そこでこの膨らみ縮みでもなく
全く違う現象が出てくるんですね
それまた世界はすごい大きいんだけど
いろんな違う現象が出て
今まで見たことがないものとかね
だから単なる膨らみ縮みとかそういうことではなくて
ちょっとレベルものすごく違う瞑想が出てきて
そちらにも統一性ありまして
そこで現象のレベルがありましてね
ある日は体軽くなったと
ある日は光見えたと ある日は音が消えたと
ある人は体がなんかブルブルブルブルと
そんなもんは全部パリカルマなんです
[笑い]だから体ブルブルしてたらあなたどうやって知ったんですかと
光見えたらあなたどんな対処
態度を取ったかと 大人になったかと
そこはチェックするんですね
大人にならなかったら永久的にそこでストップになっちゃうし
で 自己自慢したければそれで大損をしてそこで終わっちゃうし
まあそこはそれぞれの個人次第ですけど
とにかくそういういろんな現象が出てきて
出てきて 消えていって
消えていって まあほとんどの人は現象の出るまではやってませんから
あまり心配してないんだけど
で 現象出てきて やがて落ち着いて
全ては統一して 何か一つだけ見えるようになってくる
感じるようになってくる
それはウペチャーラ・ニミッタなんですね
ウペチャーラ・ニミッタの次
本当のアッパナー・ニミッタが生まれてきて瞑想になっちゃいます
ですから このあなた 瞑想して何を体験したかということも勉強しておかないとダメなんです
私は神様が体験したとかね
私は瞑想していると あの
何でしたっけ マイトレーヤが現れたんだとかね
私の後ろでマイトレーヤ神様が
今は流行ってますからね
まあもう立っていましたと
もうバジャン唱えていると
ちゃんとサーイババがちらっとそこで揺れていったんだとかね
だからまさに事実ですよという人々がいます
だからまあそうやって
耳の中であるいは頭の中でずっとこの経典やら聖書の賛美歌やらずっと聞けているんだとか
みんな自分の神秘体験持ってますね
だからみんな自分のものはどうだい
私の子はという感じで
あの子供を自慢するあの親バカどもみたいに
あのどうだいと 私の子はどうだいというのはいいんだけど
なんかあっちこっちでいる犬を買ってきてペット自慢するような感じで
どうだい私の子はという感じで意味がないんでそれは
どうせペットだから 猫は猫だから
犬は犬だからね 犬だからオスだったらどうせおしっこする場合は足一本上げておしっこするし
どこでどっちででも同じことだから
あまり素晴らしいってことはないんです
そういうことで この瞑想の世界で人類が体験するいろんな瞑想
神秘体験 すべて三つに分けてるんです
ウペチャーラの時現れる対象現象
リハサルの瞬間で現れる現象と本番の時
サマーディ状態の瞬間の現れる対象
そこら辺は統一しています
問題はここから進めないことですね
みんな だからたくさん神秘体験持ってる連中がいるんです
その神秘体験レベルを乗り越えたならば
ほとんどみんな結構似ている経験になるはずなんです
じゃあまあ時間になりましたので
どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございました